good afternoon thank you for being here
this afternoon i wanted to take some
time today to provide a few important
updates
related to the state's current covit 19
mitigation measures
but first i want to take a moment to
provide an update on the progress of
vaccination in nevada
i am so grateful to the state team
that's been working hard
to provide support to our local partners
and focusing on efficiency
and equity as we continue to roll out
this historic vaccination campaign
a little over a month ago i asked the
nevada national guard division of
emergency management
and the state immunization team to work
together to identify challenges
and implement solutions the results have
been remarkable
it should make us all proud earlier this
week
fema released a report indicating that
nevada continues to perform among the
top in the country
in administering the state's allocation
of vaccine
that's something to be proud of we know
we can do more
with more doses and the dedication and
hard work of partners statewide
has been instrumental but there is more
work to be done
as of yesterday more than 307
000 first doses have been administered
to nevadans
and reported the state system along with
over 82
000 second doses totaling more than
390 000 doses administered statewide
i want to thank our federal partners who
in recent weeks have provided
substantial support
to our state in the form of personnel
providing
a staff to help alleviate the data
backlog and vaccinators to get more
shots in
arms we continue to work closely with
the new administration
and federal agencies and remain
optimistic about the increase in direct
and regular
communication and support
my staff and i are in contact every day
with representatives from the federal
government to get more vaccines
finally thank you to our many local
partners including the local leaders
vaccinators volunteers and organizers on
the ground
this is a herculean task and now it
would not be possible without your
tireless efforts
every time a challenge is identified we
are finding a solution
most importantly we are ready and able
to vaccinate more nevadans
as soon as we get more doses we are
grateful for the recent increase in
doses from the federal government
but we know nevada's are anxious to be
vaccinated
and we will continue to work with our
federal delegation
to fight for more doses in addition to
receiving more doses for nevadans
it is vital that we meet our residents
where they are
we need to ensure we have locations and
communities and are able to overcome
barriers
to reach all nevadans
i'm proud of the partnerships we have
built and excited
that walmart and sam's club pharmacies
will begin administering vaccine
through the federal retail pharmacy
program more than three dozen nevada
locations will participate
offering a convenient location for
residents to make an appointment to be
vaccinated
as you all know each week nevada
receives a limited number of doses of
cobit 19 vaccine
which is a challenge for everyone but
every dose
every single dose is a small step
forward
these doses are going to locations
throughout nevada and i am proud of the
partnership we have with our statewide
coalition
immunized nevada information
on who is eligible to be vaccinated and
where vaccine is available
is all compiled by immunized nevada on
one website
that's nvcovidfider.org
each county's plan is updated there so
nevadans will know where they can make
an appointment
in their own community or
if you need a helping hand with the
process we've set up a hotline
available 8 a.m to 8 p.m seven days a
week
they can help you make an appointment or
answer a question
that number is 800-401-0946
that's 800-401-0946
and in the two weeks that the call
center has been open they have already
answered more than 25
000 calls neighbors helping neighbors
we are all in this together and i know
nevadans are looking out for each other
staying connected virtually or making
sure the seniors we know
understand how to make a plan and an
appointment
i urge all nevadans to reach out and
offer support
for those who may need it vaccines have
provided us some hope
during the worst of this pandemic like
the rest of the country
nevada experienced multiple surges over
the recent winter months
resulting in a record high statewide
positivity rate
of 21.7 in january
daily case counts that reached a high of
over 2700 that's 2700
in mid-december and our highest peak of
hospitalizations in late december
with 2126 confirmed and suspected
hospitalizations
but also like the rest of the country
nevada has recently
been experiencing steady progress in
terms of our covet 19 trends
which i know is welcome news to all of
us
as of february 11th the test positivity
rate over the last 14 days
is 14.3 the average number of daily new
cases over the last 14 days
is 684 and recently
the nevada hospitalization as hospital
association
reported nevada is continuing to see a
downward trajectory in hospitalizations
as of february 10th nevada had 870
confirmed and suspected hospitalizations
these are significant decreases and i'm
grateful
that the statewide pause as difficult as
it has been
has helped nevada mitigate the spread
while covered transmission was surging
across the country
i am grateful to nevadans across the
state who continue to stay home when
they can
to mask up to socially distance and
follow other
mitigation measures to protect
themselves and each other
it's important to look back at where
we've been as we chart our new path
forward
our recent progress is significant but
we also started
at record highs across the board and our
trends today are still double
what we experienced in mid-september
after recovering from the summer surge
in fact the nevada hospital association
warns that this good news
does not mean that people should let
their guard down with case counts
remaining near the previous waves high
hospital capacity could quickly be
stressed if the trajectories change
course
we can't let that happen that's why the
next steps we take must be strategic
and responsible as we continue
navigating this pandemic
and ramping up our vaccination efforts
through an efficient and equitable
approach
plans for safe reopening must focus on
how we can continue mitigating the
spread
while getting nevadans back to work
protecting
and recovering our economy and getting
our students back to
in-person learning in the safest way
possible
let me repeat getting our students back
to in-person learning
in the safest way possible according to
state public health officials
a critical component of a successful
reopening plan
is that we continue to follow the
mitigation measures
that are proven to work while
incrementally loosening restrictions
i also know that after making it through
the very difficult winter surges
and the pause nevada nevadans want and
deserve predictability
about what our path forward will look
like
this is what was front of mind as we
developed this roadmap to recovery safe
reopening plan
this plan is aimed at ensuring success
for the long term
and not just in the immediate and
providing predictability
through a clear timeline that's why
today i am announcing our timeline for a
safe reopening
which starts this monday february 15th
and goes through may first in a moment
i'll walk through more specifics
but i wanted to start by providing a
quick overview
beginning on monday february 15th a
first round of capacity limits will be
lifted
at various levels based on risk level of
the activity or business type identified
by health experts
gatherings will be lifted to allow 100
people
or 35 capacity whichever is less
with strict social distancing
additionally large gathering plans may
once again be submitted to local health
authorities for review
and then to the appropriate state
agencies for potential approval
in line with the same large gathering
plan process
initiated last fall however any approved
large gatherings can only begin to take
place starting
march 1. on march 15th
the next round of capacity and gathering
restrictions will be lifted
will the full return to pre-pause levels
this will result in almost all
businesses in the state returning to 50
capacity and gatherings to 250 people or
50
whichever is less with strict social
distancing requirements
being met finally on may first
the goal is for the state to transition
to decision making
authority on mitigation management of
businesses and activities to local
authorities
i'll speak more on this big step in a
moment
as we age ease restrictions we must
follow the science and studies which
states clearly and repeatedly
that closures to certain settings are
more impactful in reducing disease
transmission
according to the experts mitigation
measures in these high-risk areas
should be extended longer and eased
responsibly to help slow the spread
to be clear businesses or activities
deemed higher risk by scientific
evidence
are not the fault of business owners or
anyone else
i know our bar and restaurant owners and
others are doing everything they can to
keep their staff and customers safe
the unfortunate reality is that covid 19
transmission
risk increases with a number of
individuals in one location
the ability to wear masks the amount of
ventilation
and the length of exposure for example
individuals dining indoors are likely to
remain in the location for a longer
length of time with their masks removed
and sufficient ventilation cannot be
guaranteed
that's why we will take this responsible
approach and ensure all settings have
the support they need
to reopen safely beginning on february
15th
here is what will be what will be moving
to 35
capacity places of worship gyms
fitness studios yoga studios martial
arts studios and similar establishments
gaming floors arcades race tracks
bowling alleys pool halls
and similar activities when it comes to
restaurants and bars
indoor dining and beverage service will
be capped at 35
capacity outdoor dining will not have a
capacity limit
but we'll have to adhere to all social
distancing requirements
reservations will no longer be necessary
on
starting on february 15th and we will
increase the allowed number of patrons
per table
from four to six the following will be
moving to 50
on february 15th libraries museums
art galleries aquariums and zoos
additionally public gatherings and
events can increase to 100 individuals
or 35 percent of fire code capacity
finally organizations may begin
submitting large gathering plans
beginning on
february 15th but no events can resume
until march first
and only if reviewed by local health
authorities and approved by the
appropriate state agencies
the same process that was in place prior
to the initiation
of the pause venues eligible for large
gatherings
will be capped at 20 percent of the
total fixed seat capacity
and must follow strict social distancing
requirements
and be able to adhere to all mitigation
protocols
and again they will only be able to take
place if their submitted plan is
reviewed
reviewed by the appropriate local health
authority and approved by the state
the next big date is march 15th on march
15th
all the businesses operating at 35
percent will be able to move to 50
capacity public gatherings will also
move to 250 people
or 50 capacity with this will return the
state to full pre-pause levels
from now until may 1st retail stores
indoor malls
and community and recreation centers
will remain at 50
spas massage establishments hair salons
barber shops nail salons
and other businesses that provide
aesthetics skin services
will continue to operate under strict
social distancing
and under the authority of the
applicable state licensing boards
additionally certain high-risk
businesses and activities
adult entertainment establishments
nightclubs and day clubs and brothels
will remain closed until at least may
1st
and finally may 1st marks the date where
we hope to reach our ultimate goal of
transitioning
mitigation management to local authority
in order to reach this goal the counties
will have from now through the end of
april to demonstrate
a decrease in covert trends hospital
capacity within their region
and evidence that they can continue
performing at an adequate level of
testing
and other response efforts for their
communities
even when we move to local management
specific statewide
protocols will remain in place to
mitigate the spread including but not
limited to the mass mandate
and other social distancing requirements
between now and then the covet 19
management and mitigation task force
will work with counties to develop plans
that will help prepare
for a smooth transition to local control
beginning may
1. the task force will also continue to
monitor the covet 19 situation in each
area of nevada
provides state assistance as needed to
ensure
we continue to see improvements and as
always
while we are hopeful that trends will
continue to decrease
if all mid if if all mitigation measures
are followed
we must remain flexible as we have done
all along
we will continue to monitor data trends
throughout this timeline
and work closely with counties and local
health authorities
to evaluate next steps should a
significant increase begin to occur
now i want to speak directly to local
leaders i know your communities trust
you
they trust you the most i know that you
know that too
that's why i'm asking for you to talk
directly to your neighbors
about the importance of getting the next
75 days right
so you can go back to the local level
and manage
this the way you think works best for
your community
the best part of this plan is that it's
in the hands of every nevadan
every community if we all want to see
this transition to local control
let's work together to continue
decreasing our community transmission
providing an adequate amount of time
between the first step of reopening
and the transitional local authority at
the county level
allows local governments the time to
prepare for the transition
allows the state to monitor the impact
of vaccinations and allows public health
officials
time to monitor any potential impacts of
the new covet 19 variants
most importantly and as i have said
repeatedly one of my main priorities is
to get children
back to school in the safest way
possible
to date 16 of our 17 counties have been
able
to bring students and educators back in
some fashion
clark county school district our largest
school district
has also been working hard to make this
happen but as of today
more than 300 000 students have not been
in the club inside a classroom
for close to a year for close to 365
days
they've not seen the inside of a
classroom fortunately on march first
students in pre-k through third grade
will have the opportunity to return to
school
in clark county recently the cdc has
said
that school reopening can be done in a
safe way
but only if we're doing everything we
can to manage community transmission
outside of the school walls this
reopening timeline takes this into
consideration
we have to make sure we're doing
everything we can as a state
to make sure the reopening of our
largest district is successful
in addition to protecting the students
that are already back in classrooms
throughout the state
these children our educators our bus
drivers our school nurses
they are worth protecting and
prioritizing in this moment
i know all nevadans will agree we're
going to make it through this
the goal of this plan is to devoid a
scenario
where i have to come back before all of
you again and pause our efforts
i don't want to do that i believe this
plan can
work i believe it will work but we must
all invest in making it successful 75
days to the trust the science
listen to our public health experts mask
up
get a vaccine if eligible practice
social distancing
and see your numbers decline i want to
see our children return to in-person
learning in the safest way possible
i want to see nevada's get back to work
i want to see small businesses thrive i
want to help relaunch our missed and
needed convention business
including the world of concrete
convention taking place in las vegas
this june i want to see business travel
to nevada to make a comeback
boosting our economy and putting folks
back to work
i want to give our health care workers a
needed break from 11 straight months of
shift
after shift after shift caring for the
covet patients
i want to return to nevada we know and
we love but i want to come back even
stronger
together we can do this there is hope in
nevada
shots are getting into arms and the
american rescue plan
brought forward by the biden harris
administration is moving through
congress that plan will bring nevada
much needed assistance
and much needed relief that plan
paired with the vaccination efforts will
be a tremendous help to the state of
nevada
but until then we must continue to
mitigate the spread thank you all for
being here
i will now take some questions from
members of the media on the call
i think some of my staff is here on the
line to help coordinate
and facilitate this process thank you
governor sister this is megan delaney
tom's director i see i have folks
already raising their hands
if you're a member of the media on the
call and you want to ask the governor a
question please
feel free to use the race hand option um
if you go under reactions there should
be a raise hand button
so i saw bill denser from the rj first
and then we'll go to megan metzerly
after that so bill if you can unmute
yourself you can ask the governor your
question
thanks again thanks governor for doing
this a couple of
questions on vaccines so you mentioned
390
000 have been administered i'm wondering
how many have actually been received
here
and if there's any kind of bottleneck
between getting them deployed here and
getting them into people's arms
and then second part of that is is there
a time frame at this point
for when uh the state thinks they'll get
um
certain benchmarks for number of people
vaccinated well i mean i
we have a regular call i think it's
three times a week with uh candace and
caleb about the number of vaccines that
we're getting
versus a number that are actually going
into arms i can tell you that
fema has recommended is acknowledged
that we're amongst the top states
in administering vaccines that are given
to us
i cannot give you a timeline in terms of
one
we can get to that part where all
nevadans can get a vaccine because
there's so much more happening
uh more vaccines are being provided
hopefully have been ordered i said today
president of biden acknowledge ordered
another 200 doses
of the vaccine the jnj vaccine should be
coming online hopefully within the next
month or so
there's a couple other companies that
are during the process of asking for
approval so
that's a work in progress and i can
commit to you and verify the fact that
every day my staff and i are on the
phone with our leaders in washington
talking about this very issue and
fighting to get every single dose into
the state
thanks bill we'll do megan messerly and
then after megan will go to vanessa
murphy on deck i think those are the
right baseball terms
thanks thanks for doing this governor um
another vaccine question for you so
we're seeing a lot of folks getting
vaccinated as frontline community
support workers because their industry
is prioritized for vaccination
even though they work from home and
therefore are not recommended for
prioritization under the state's
vaccination playbook
there's currently no way right now to
verify at mass vaccination sites whether
people who've made appointments are true
frontline workers with exposure to the
public do you see this as a problem and
what do you plan to do as governor to
address this
well you know my staff and our team has
put forward a tremendous amount of time
putting the playbook together and i
think they've done a tremendous job
that's been disseminated and distributed
to all of the local health districts
and where it's incumbent upon them to
make sure that that playbook is followed
uh i think they're doing a relatively
good job they're doing what they can
there are always going to be isolated
cases you see that all over the country
whether someone is as you call jump the
line or not quite be qualified
but we're doing everything humanly
possible to get needles in people's arms
as quickly as possible
thanks megan i think i said vanessa next
and then we'll do
on stam maps from the ap thanks for
taking my question
governor siselek you may have seen how
we're experiencing long lines at
vaccination sites
the clark county convention center is an
example today with seniors
70 and up standing for hours
with all due respect to the hard work
going into this and while i know you
don't
run the southern nevada health district
is it time for the state to team
up to try to help fix technical issues
to perhaps do drive-through vaccination
sites
um they're doing those drive-throughs in
california
well we have uh my team has been in
southern nevada they're working with
southern nevada to help alleviate
uh these situations we're taking federal
advice
as it becomes available on this we
certainly don't want our seniors our
most vulnerable standing in line for
hours
you know i hear that they're standing in
line for hours and then the health
district is telling me that
you know 15 of the people aren't showing
up for appointments and there's
duplicate appointments
this is an enormous a herculean task to
undertake
we're doing everything we can i
encourage people to make an appointment
and show up at their appointment time
for the vaccine
that's the best way to assure that you
don't have to stand in line
but for right now the health districts
the local districts who are closest to
the people
are the ones that are responsible for
administering the vaccines
setting the appointments and and taking
care of those
individuals thank you vanessa we'll go
to sam next and then we'll do john
sadler of the sun
after sam go ahead sam hey governor
thank you so much for taking my question
sure when you say that statewide
guidelines will remain in place in the
counties
and the task force will help transition
plans starting in march i want to
clarify
will the plans require task force
approval and can you explain what it
means in terms of local
control that statewide guidelines
remaining in place will quote
include but not be limited to face
covering in social distancing safety
protocols
which ones do you mean the transition in
may
you say the transition in may that the
road map says
um the task force will start planning
for in march
right the test they'll start making
preparation that hopefully
in may it's our goal and our desire to
turn this over again to the local
communities that are closest to the
individuals to the businesses
and give them the authority to set
regulations and protocols
as it relates to covet mitigation now
the state will be here to help them
with those protocols to provide
information to provide data
and to ensure that they are
meeting the factors so they speak that
the positivity rate continues to go down
the cases continue to go down that
there's an adequate hospitalization
this is not an either or this is a
collaboration that we're
doing with the local health districts to
assure that they're ready
at that time in order to do that to
accomplish it because it's in everyone's
best interest
that we can get this over to the local
jurisdictions and it's our goal to do
that
like i say by may
so like after may 1st would counties
have the freedom to reopen things like
brothels or would the state still need
to review and improve that
well that's something that's open it's
the same that is open that
you know we're going to continue to keep
some things in place certainly the mask
mandate
the social distancing the details of how
we can put it over
are going to have to be worked out
because we've got cities inside of
counties
and some counties are larger than other
counties so these are
all factors that we're going to have to
work out but we've got 75 days to do
that
and i'm sure that in collaboration with
our partners we'll be able to get it
done
thank you thank you sam thanks governor
i think i said john sadler would be next
and then we'll do um jacqueline schultz
from fox 5 after john
sam if you're able to lower your hand on
your end that would be great
hi governor can you hear me i sure can
thanks for doing this um i had
just kind of a clarification question
when you say you're transitioning or
hope to transition to local authorities
on may 1st
is this county is going to be control is
there any city control involved with
this could you explain a little bit
about that
that is one of the situations that we're
going to have to work through the uh
the counties and the cities to see what
the most uh
effective method would be there's going
to be some jurisdictions where
obviously there's going to be an overlap
and you've got several large cities or
cities inside of a county and
an unincorporated county might be there
but those are things that we hope that
everybody can get together
those local jurisdictions to come up
with a plan that would benefit everybody
and give them the resources necessary
thanks john i think i said jacqueline
schultz was on deck and after jacqueline
we'll go to james dehaven i know james
he said you're having trouble raising
your hands so thanks for sending me the
chat
so jacqueline and then jane hi governor
can you hear me
i can
go ahead sure great uh governor
you um is clark county doing enough at
this point
to vaccinate minorities in zip codes
that are challenged with high positivity
rates
are they addressing that problem that
you raised and
when can clark county when realistically
with the doses we're getting could we
eventually even get into the general
population
well you know i i made my point very
clear as it related to the underserved
population
and the inequity that existed who i felt
in vaccinations i know that the counties
are aware of that
i know that the local leaders are aware
of that i know that the health districts
are aware of that
and it's incumbent upon them to take
that information and hopefully
uh move forward with it i don't want to
say they're doing
enough or not doing enough they've been
great partners
but equity is about access everyone is
working hard at this and i just want to
reassure you
that this is an enormous herculean task
you know my biggest effort that i put
forward every day i come in here and i
leave here
making the next phone call to get more
vaccines into the state of nevada
my staff spends an entire day on the
phone talking to the cdc
to fema to the fda to all the various
agencies
about potential getting more vaccines in
here so we can plan and be ready for
distributing that
it's my hope and my goal that in the
foreseeable future
as the president has said we'll have
enough vaccines to open it up to just
everybody
and eliminate a lot of the these
problems right now there are more
people wanting the vaccine than we have
vaccines to give and that'll continue
for a while but we're fighting
every single day to get more vaccines in
here and we're working with our local
partners
to make sure those are distributed in an
equitable
and fair manner thanks for the question
jacqueline thanks governor we'll do
james and then we'll go marry hinds from
the rj after that
hey governor how you doing good i'm
curious if the state will
step back in in the event that you know
after the transition to local authority
in the event that a county experience is
a surge in cases
does the state swoop in or how does that
work well the state's always going to be
here to provide help
and to provide assistance and to provide
information
we have data that they can use we have
information
and we have an infrastructure that they
can use you know we want to give this to
the local jurisdictions
uh whether that be the cities or the
counties but i'm confident we can work
this together
you know that we can make this work and
if they need our help and they need us
to step back in and
provide more guidance we're here and
willing to do that but they're the
closest to the people to the citizens
and i think it's fair that they have the
opportunity to make changes to make
adjustments and and together we'll make
this work but it's a collaboration it's
a team effort
thank you james thank you governor we'll
do mary hines and then we'll do terry
russell after that you
good afternoon hey mary hey governor
um i've spoken to some public health
authorities who say that nevada's
cases and under and other indicators
although improved remain very high
too high to begin easing restrictions
what do you say to that mary this has
been a difficult issue and i hear this
every day
some people want you to open everything
up some people want you to close
everything down
some people want you to have no capacity
limits others want
strict capacity limits some people want
schools open
someone's school is closed every
decision that we've had to make
that i've had to make for the last year
has been fraught with
there's two sides to it it is a
difficult tight rope
balancing act to attempt to keep our
people as safe as we can by vaccinating
them protecting our health care workers
and our hospital capacity and at the
same time
get our economy moving we've got
unemployment that's still too high
i've got too many people that are out of
work that are looking to go to work
and businesses that are struggling and
hanging on by a threat
and i encourage everybody out there
that's listening to this mary patronize
a small business when you can buy a gift
card
get me food to go from a small business
give these people a chance
that they can keep their businesses
going because they've been there for us
and we need to be there for them but
it's always going to be criticized
whether we do more or do less and we're
trying to find that balancing that
middle spot and
and i think we're doing well in terms of
doing that and we're going to get
through this together and come out
stronger on the
on the back end thank you mary thank you
governor we'll go to
terry and then we'll go to jackie valley
if you're having trouble raising your
hand and you've messaged me i see you
even if i'm not responding so
thank you for that terry and then jackie
governor
uh you're trying to get more
vaccinations you've encouraged
medical professionals to uh go to serve
nevada
sign up to volunteer and i have been
getting some
many many inquiries from local
physicians here
who indicate that the serve nevada
website is for future emergencies
that it's full of bureaucracy
specifically it's asking them to perform
a uh full background check which they've
all agreed to
but they say we are not in a future
emergency we're in an emergency now
and shouldn't the uh a license in good
standing
with the medical board as well as
hospital privileges
suffice to be able to deliver a shot in
the arm considering many of these people
are
doing surgeries doing anesthesia
delivering babies
and many of them have filled the forms
out and have waited
more than a month and have not heard
from counties
anybody else about where their standing
is to volunteer their
time yet they're now able to volunteer
their time and deliver shots at local
hospitals
well you know that's a difficult
situation i appreciate terry the
question
uh we are working with our local health
jurisdictions
to to accommodate this we appreciate the
volunteerism spirit
understand a lot of these folks want to
vaccinate in their offices
we don't know if they have adequate
storage facilities to put vaccines in
there
a lot of them are willing them to uh
come to a location we have loosened the
requirements for vaccinators
the reality is i'm more i'm short of
vaccines i'm not sure the vaccinators
right now the hope is
that in the immediate future short-term
future we'll get enough vaccines that
then i'll need these vaccinators right
now
i'm not getting shots in arms as a lack
of vaccinators as there's a lack of
vaccines
and we're doing everything we can to get
more of those
thank you governor thank you terry i
believe dhhs is working with you on that
as well so we can try to loop back and
get you some more information if you may
need it
i think i had jackie valley of the indy
next and then we'll take shay johnson
from the rj after jackie
yes thank you governor my question is
this there's been talk about whether
domestic travel restrictions would help
curb
the spread of new cova variants do you
support such domestic travel
restrictions in areas experiencing
outbreaks of those new variants
i don't know what kind of restrictions
you're talking about jackie if you're
talking about testing or proof of
a negative test or vaccine before they
get on an airline
a flight that's regulated by the faa and
you know hopefully they're
listening i know they're listening to
everybody's input but
like i say that that gets into the the
nuances of
you know what the restriction should be
or shouldn't be as results in air travel
and uh obviously it's my goal to get as
many people as we can once we're through
this
and recovering into the state where we
can help our economy recover at the same
time it has to be done
in a safe basis but i know there's a lot
of smart people at the faa working on
how they should be handled
in airports and on airplanes
thanks jackie we'll do shea johnson and
then i had two folks i had brett forrest
and howard
stutz in the chat and then we'll
probably pull to a close after those so
shay and then brett and then howard
thanks guys
are you able to unmute yourself and ask
a question i think i just heard you
i am hi good afternoon governor hey um
in clark county local governments have
offered all
their employees or in some cases most or
many of their employees
opportunities to be vaccinated under
this continuity of
governance category within the playbook
have you been satisfied with how local
governments have interpreted the
guidance
in the playbook with respect to
continuity of governance and
does giving access to a broad group of
government employees align with the
playbook's intentions
shay it's been my goal since the
beginning and i'll make it clear we had
two
uh buckets or trails or tracks whatever
it might be
in terms of how to get the vaccine the
first is to our
age categories you know uh 70 and over
to get vaccines in their arms and
there's a second category
for our front line workers now whether
those essential workers know whether
those are how it's interpreted
the front line the essential workers and
the continuance of governance
is helpful to the local health districts
i'm not standing
in one of the vaccinations lines asking
to see people's id
and where they work it's responsibility
of the health districts
to make sure that the vaccines are going
to the right people now
understand there's a personal
responsibility here as well
because if there's a group of people or
a group of individuals or whatever it
might be that are getting vaccines that
really shouldn't be getting them
they're taking those vaccines away from
people that need them
they're taking them away from your 85 90
year old grandmother or parent
they're taking them away from the front
line worker who's been working
every single day during this pandemic or
the health care worker
that's working to shift every single day
to take care of us if the vaccine's
going to somebody
that shouldn't be getting it it's taking
it from someone who should
it's not a matter of there's no
consequence to it the matter is that
we're trying to get it in uh the people
that are most desperately required to
have it as soon as possible
and that's the local health districts
that are responsible
for administering and complying with
that playbook and i'm counting on them
to do that
thank you shea thanks governor we'll do
brett forrest and then howard and then
we'll pull to a close
hi governor brett forrest here um could
we just get some clarification
on the youth sports resuming march 15th
is that going to include the high school
sports and what about the sports on the
do not play list like football will
those end up being able to be played
this year
uh we're working through that right now
as we speak brett is something that my
team has been in contact with the nia
several times a week to determine that
there are club sports are now currently
allowed
uh your soccer your baseball softball
that sort of thing
uh we're working on bringing some more
tournaments allowing some more
tournaments to come back in
and that's something that we didn't
quite get done before today's press
conference
but we hope to have some guidance in
that area in the next few days
but we are currently working with the
club sports folks
and the niaa but when you talk about the
high school sports
i'm going to cut right to the chase my
primary concern is to get him in a
classroom
i'd like to get him on a court i'd like
to get him on a
a baseball field a soccer field football
field whatever it is i'd love to see
that happen
but first i want to get him in a math
class and an english class if i can and
that's where
our emphasis has been but we are working
on sports
thank you governor thanks brett for the
question we'll go to howard steps for
the last one today gov
good morning good afternoon governor how
you doing good howard how are you doing
good couple questions the last the last
call you did you talked about
moving casino workers um or
up in the front line employees for for
vaccinations of you know the hotel
tourism
i was curious where that stands and then
the other question deals with
um when you transfer transition this
over on may first
was won't the gaming control board have
ultimate say of what happens with the
casinos and
you know on the strip and downtown and
in reno you know going
rather than over the local authorities
well let me answer your second question
first howard and
nobody knows more about the gaming
industry and hospitality industry than
you
i mean you've been around a long time
you do a lot of writing on it i know
you're an authority that people go to
yes to answer your question the gaming
control board
and the commission ultimately have
authority over any licensed property
and they can always step in they can
always make uh
requirements they can always issue
violation notices they can always issue
fines so
would go to the local governments to
work with the gaming control board but
ultimately
the gaming control board would make that
call if it came down to that
as it relates to the the workers our
frontline workers
hospitality workers and i want to be
crystal clear about this
are yes they are prioritized for
vaccines
now we're one of the few states that
have done that because we totally
understand
the importance of our hospitality
workers i mean i talked to the culinary
workers and they've lost members
to this disease have passed away and
it's important that
every one of these folks that are having
a face-to-face
interaction with our tourists that are
coming here get a vaccine and are
protected
and we want to do that for several
reasons one we want to protect our
our workers and our residents in two i
want everybody coming here to know that
this is the safest place to come for a
vacation
you can come here you don't have to
worry about one of the hospitality
workers
uh potentially infecting you so yes they
are prioritized
and yes the gaming control board
ultimately
under the leadership of the chairman
brynn gibson
has control over that those issues
thanks governor
thank you thanks everyone for joining us
today we'll have
some more information on the governor's
plan that we'll send out and that will
post on
nvhealthresponse.nv.gov as soon as we
pull to a close here
so thank you governor and thank you
everyone for joining us
thank you all
over that those issues thanks governor
thank you thanks everyone for joining us
today we'll have
um some more information on the
governor's plan that we'll send out and
that we'll post on
envyhealthresponse.nv.gov as soon as we
pull to a close here
so thank you governor and thank you
everyone for joining us
thank you all